-It's time for "WeTweet." Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we as a group
decide something that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five different tweets and we're all
going to vote on whether you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers in your seats.
You can all vote for them.
You can vote for all of them. You can vote for none of them.
You pick which one you enjoy... -Yep.
-...and you press the green one, thumbs up, if you like it,
thumbs down if you do not like it.
They're pretty good.
I think -- I think I know which one's going to go.
-Really?
-It could be the first one, I think.
That's why I want to warn you guys.
'Cause this is the first time the first one could be the one.
-So you're saying first one and then downhill?
-No, I'm just saying first one should be --
Just don't let -- Don't sleep on it.
-Okay.
-Roots and Higgins, you all have clickers, right?
-I've already cast all my votes.
-No, no. We didn't even read -- No, no.
We didn't read the tweets yet. So --
-You already did it? -Whatever -- No.
Don't -- Stop, dude. Stop clicking on it.
It doesn't work right now.
Whatever tweet gets the most likes, we're going to tweet it
out live in the show so that you can all like it
and then WeTweet it.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Oh, snap! -Snap!
-Snap! -"Oh, Snap" is on Wednesdays.
-Yeah. -This is "WeTweet."
Here we go. Are you guys ready for this?
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. -Now, saying it --
-Yeah. -Saying it out loud.
-You kind of sold that one. -Saying it out loud,
I don't know.
I still got to get my vote in there.
-Yeah. You're gonna vote "yes." -I enjoy it.
Yeah, I like that one.
I could read that and enjoy it and go, "That's funny."
-Oh. "I like that tweet."
-Yeah, you got the kind of "just woke up" face.
-Yeah. -Yeah, I like it.
-Cool. -Alright, here we go.
The votes are in. Let's see the results from this one.
-Oh, my God. [ Sad tuba plays ]
-Why would you do that to me?! Why would you do that to me
after I warned you that it might be --
-They turned on you fast.
-Alright. This next one is...
Yeah, now you hope --
Now you wish you voted for that first one.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Let's see the results.
Yeah. There you go. These are all bad.
Didn't like that one, either. [ Sad tuba plays ]
♪ Dumplings ♪ -♪ Dumplings ♪
-Alright. This next one is...
-Wha-- What? So they stopped reading the book?
-That's correct. -They went...
-"That's not where I left off. That's where I left."
-"Yeah. I'm out of here." -Yeah.
Alright. Here we go. Let's see the results on this one.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lot of readers. Lot of readers out there.
-That's the winner with 115, right?
-115 is the winner, yeah, yeah.
But we have two more left, right?
-Okay. Thank God. -Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That could be the winner.
-Yeah. Heck yeah. That one's fine.
-They're all fun. -They're all fine.
-Yeah. This one is...
♪♪
-I thought I was the only one that did that.
-Yeah.
Alright. I'm kind of good with that vote there.
I don't know. I'm not feeling great about that one.
Let's see the results. -I say 116.
-110!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-That's a dead heat right there. Wow.
-Wow. This is split up. -A very divided audience.
They know what they want. -Yeah, and it's not these.
-They're waiting for number five.
-Number five's the winner.
-=They're waiting for number five.
All chips are -- -Yes, all-in.
-I think we know this one is going to be the one.
-I'm going to vote now. -No, don't vote.
Wait till I read it.
Last one is...
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's spicy. -That's spicy, yeah.
That's a spicy one there.
People are laughing. People are laughing.
The Roots are playing a little groove to it.
Everyone's kind of into that one.
I think this is going to be the one.
-♪ Get it on ♪ -What's your guess?
-I'm going to say this is number one.
-Are you going to say, like, what? Like, 188?
-I'm going to say -- No. With this, I'm saying 126.
-I'm going to say this is in the 150-160 range.
-160?
-I'm going to go ahead and say 220.
-You're saying 100% of the audience voted for it?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. -Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-100%. Everybody voted for it? Including all of us.
-Do you know who's in the audience tonight?
-What's that? -Dusty Johnson.
-Ha! Really? -He's here tonight.
-He's the one who hooked up on the loveseat.
-Yeah, yeah. No, it was the couch.
-Oh. -Can we see the results?
[ Drum roll ]
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, snap! Oh!
-Dude, you almost got it! 202.
That's the winner right there.
I will post this during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed, give it a like.
Give it a WeTweet and enjoy.